fans were eagerly awaiting the arrival
of bridgeton season two there you go now
you're done it's finally here the show
amassed 193 million hours viewed in its
first three days of release setting a
netflix record for the opening weekend
of an english language series but some
fans are a little disappointed
by the lack of sex scenes so
right
only in 2022 and because people be
complaining about this so yes as we know
the first season was full of steamy love
scenes featuring the charming ricochet
pawn page you know he he showed things
phoebe uh as well the season tells the
story of lord anthony bridgeton's quest
for love and features just two sex
scenes in eight episodes how will we go
now
actually has responded to fans watching
those r-rated scenes during a recent
appearance on the tamron hall show
here's what she had to say
i mean um it's understandable because i
know that was
a big characteristic of season one but
you know this season we're kind of
exploring intimacy in a more
psychological way a slow burn is always
a little bit more steamier in my opinion
um it's much more earned so when it does
eventually reach that moment
fireworks are just huge and it's just a
little bit more juicier the word juicier
here's the thing let me break this down
for you who breaks it down for me okay
this is the reason people are really
upset by it because the second book is
supposed to be more steamy and more sex
scenes so they didn't go there they went
the other way to tease you into it like
there's scenes where there's wet shirts
and there's moments of touching and
there's all these just setting up for
the love scene which i like
i love the little teasing through the
episodes so having two scenes
out of eight episodes i think that's
great the other thing is i have to say
we don't see a lot of south asian women
in these roles so to see them do
something this big i was like my mom's
reacting right away i was like oh my god
my mom can't watch this but uh i thought
it was absolutely fabulous i didn't
think season two was gonna be great and
i think is awesome and i think people
enjoy i don't know why people need more
sex scenes what is happening what is
happening you don't need two's enough
it's enough